éducation toujours depuis le 25 janvier
les universités peuvent faire revenir
sur leur site les étudiants qui le
souhaitent
et quelle que soit leur année à
condition de ne pas dépasser dans chaque
salle de cours une jauge de 20%
ça c'est sur le papier mais dans la
réalité où en sommes-nous
les étudiants dont le mal-être est de
plus en plus flagrant ont-ils retrouvé
leur amphithéâtre
on fait le point ce soir avec le
président de l'université de tours
arnaud giacometti ou bonsoir
soit vous êtes donc le président de
l'université de tours il y a deux
semaines emmanuel macron préconisait que
tous les étudiants qu'ils souhaitent
puissent revenir à l'université au moins
un jour par semaine chez nous qu'en est
il alors c'est une ouverture qui se fait
de manière progressive parce que bon on
a eu quand même des annonces on va dire
un peu nouvelle tout toutes les semaines
donc ça se met pas en place comme ça du
jour au lendemain
donc la rampe à titre d'exemple la
semaine prochaine pendant la filière
droit économie sciences sociales ont sur
la semaine on accueillera 1500 étudiants
qui vont pouvoir revenir sur site
il est vrai que la semaine d'après on
sera à 4500 donc presque tous les
étudiants qui pourrait revenir
comment ça va fonctionner alors comment
ça fonctionne on essaye de les faire
venir au mieux uniquement par 2000
journée parce qu'on avait un peu le
problème du repas de midi
alors ça on a eu une annonce là juste là
avant de venir comme quoi finalement les
restaurants universitaires pourraient à
nouveau accueillir des étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent prendre leur repas voilà
évidemment en respectant des règles
sanitaires
donc ça ce qui va faciliter encore le
retour sur site les parties elles ont eu
lieu à la mi-décembre et de la
mi-décembre à peu près la fin janvier en
présentiel ou existentielle
quels sont les résultats est ce que est
ce que vous avez remarqué que le niveau
est plus bas alors on n'a pas encore
suffisamment de résultats
enfin pour vous dire à quelle est la
tendance la seule chose positive c'est
qu'on voit que finalement on a pas moins
d'étudiants qui sont venus aux examens
donc
présenté parfois plus que d'habitude
donc il ya peut-être là eu un peu moins
de décrochage ce qui montre qu'ils ont
fait vraiment des efforts
maintenant qu'elle saura vraiment la
qualité des résultats d'examens on sait
pas et plus généralement selon vous
quelle sera la la valeur de ces 10 pts
diplôme obtenu en 2020 2021 alors moi je
pense que ça va pas être des diplômes au
rabais ce vrai qu'il ya des craintes par
rapport à ça moi de mon inquiétude plus
tôt c'était plus d'échecs
potentiellement donc ça on sera voilà
déjà on va dire à la mi février
mais je pense vraiment pas de diplômes
au rabais après on sait que forcément
peut-être que toutes les connaissances
compétences n'auront pas été aussi bien
acquis que des années précédentes
donc c'est ce qui fait que dès
maintenant on est en train de réfléchir
un peu comment on pourrait organiser la
prochaine rentrée pour accompagner les
étudiants qui aura eu qui aurait certes
un déficit voilà qui devrait combler
dans l'année supérieure donc déjà pour
préparer cette rentrée à venir il ya les
portes ouvertes de l'université de tours
elles auront lieu dans une semaine le 13
février c'est un samedi
évidemment impossible d'accueillir les
futurs étudiants et leurs familles sur
les campus
comment ça va se passer alors ça va se
passer tout en virtuel avec 1200
intervenants qui seront là pour répondre
aux questions des étudiants et puis
parents qui voudront voilà ce se
renseigner donc c'est un peu un
événement pas facile à organiser nous
fait tout notre possible sauf ça se
passe au mieux et même des là dès lundi
on commence à avoir des live sur youtube
sur des thématiques précises parcours
super accueillants médecine endroit donc
ce sera à partir de 18h30 tous les soirs
chance connecte sur le site
universitaire l'adresse ces jpo point
unique tirer tours.fr je pense que la
guinée on est très bien guidé et il n'ya
pas besoin d'installer un outil
particulier sur sa machine c'est
uniquement via son navigateur web donc
voilà si ça fonctionne ça doit être très
simple est-ce que vous avez d'ores et
déjà autant d'inscriptions que les
années précédentes vous vous sentez un
petit ralentissement ça marche pas par
inscription par avance des étudiants
qu'on verra le jour j